hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host john carroll
and today's guest is someone i had in
mind right from the beginning as a
wonderful guest for mindscape as soon as
i started the podcast it's taken a while
for us to work it out and get it to
happen but i'm very happy to have nick
bostrom as the guest on today's podcast
nick of course is relatively famous in
the public sphere as a philosopher
because he's one of the driving forces
behind the simulation argument the idea
that it is more likely than not
that we human beings and anyone else in
our observable universe
are actually simulated consciousnesses
part of a program
being run on a computer designed and
maintained by
a far more advanced civilization but
he didn't start there nick did not first
start with the simulation argument he
got there
from his thinking in philosophy some of
his first work was on the anthropic
principle
cosmologists of course know the
anthropic principle as
trying to figure out the selection
effects that we should impose on
cosmological parameters
given the fact that we have to live in a
part of the universe where human beings
can live
but the anthropic principle is not just
for cosmologists
there's a famous version of it or i
should say a famous application of it
called the doomsday argument that goes
back to john leslie richard gott and
other people
the idea is our technological
civilization
is not that old right i mean maybe 500
years old a few thousand years old
depending on what you count as
technological civilization but the point
is let's imagine you're hoping that our
civilization
this technological peak is going to last
for millions of years
and then you say well you know the
population is only growing
so it's actually extremely unlikely
to find ourselves as people who live
right at the beginning of our
technological civilization
and therefore people like leslie and god
and others have argued
the probable lifespan of our
civilization is not that long
it's measured in thousands of years not
millions of years
so this seems a little bit presumptuous
right like how can we decide
the future lifetime of our civilization
without getting out of our armchairs
in some sense that's the philosophical
problem that people like nick bostrom
and others
have attached their thought processes to
and it leads us to think about what a
typical
observer is like and therefore as we'll
get to in the podcast
could typical observers actually be
simulated agents rather than biological
ones
this is a really fun podcast i think
it's very important stuff
nick is now at the future of life
institute at the university of oxford
where he also very famously worries
about
artificial intelligence becoming super
intelligent and doing bad things to the
world
so we'll talk a little bit about that
but mostly today
in this conversation we're about the
philosophical underpinnings we're about
how to think about these problems and i
think the conversation we have
will be very helpful to all of us when
we do so
so with that let's go
[Music]
nick bathroom welcome to the mindscape
podcast ah thanks for inviting me
so we know that you're very interested
in the future of humanity you are
literally the director
of a place called the future of humanity
institute which sounds like an awesome
responsibility
to have but uh but there's different
ways in which one can approach this
issue
of the future of humanity you can very
specifically say well this technological
change will have this certain impact and
i know that
you probably do that at the institute
but there's another angle one can take
which is more strictly philosophical and
you come from a philosophy background
there's this angle that we can just use
general principles of reasoning and very
very
meager data that we have to make
grandiose pronouncements about you know
the possible future development of
humanity and what i'm thinking of are
things like the doomsday argument
uh that you didn't originate but i know
you've had a lot to say about so
for those of us in the audience who are
not familiar with the doomsday argument
why don't you explain that a little bit
yeah okay so by context it falls within
the broader category of
uh anthropics uh reasoning about
observation selection effects
um which then comes up in different
areas i mean i know
in in the foundations of quantum physics
and cosmology
um these kind of methodological
questions become important but
the doomsday argument is one particular
application
of this style of reasoning um a
controversial one and i
at the end of the day um i'm rather
doubtful
about its soundness but what it's for
what it's worth
it goes something like this well so it
might be easiest
to explain it via an analogy um
so so let's consider a simple simple
analogy first
let's suppose that um there are two urns
and uh they are filled with balls and
you know that in one of these two urns
there are ten balls
numbered one two three up through ten
and in the other urn there are a million
balls numbered one
through a million
now somebody um flips a coin and
collects one of these urns at random
and they place it in front of you there
and they ask what's the probability
that this urn in front of you has 10
balls
so you say oh 50 right it's easy
um now let's suppose you then reach into
this urn and you pull out the ball
and you look at it it's number seven so
that then you got to update right so
you say it's not more likely that i
would get
ball number seven if there are only ten
balls in the earth
than if there were a million volts with
the urn
so you can just use space theorem you
conditionalize on this evidence and and
you get a posterior that overwhelmingly
attaches probability to the ten ball
urn hypothesis so so all of that is
non-controversial that's just our mental
probability theory
now the doomsday argument is uh
the idea that you should apply similar
reasoning to
different hypotheses about how long we
human species
will survive how many humans that would
be in the future
so instead of these two different
hypotheses about
urn now consider two different
hypotheses about the total number of
people that will ever have been born
so to keep things simple let's suppose
there are only two hypotheses
either there will be 200 billion in
total or
200 trillion in total
now corresponding to this
prior probability of 50 percent
of the earth now we are supposed to use
some empirical prior about the
different uh things that could
cause humanity to go extinct so you have
some views about the risk of nuclear
wars and meteors or
whatnot and maybe you say let's let's
suppose there's a 10
chance based on those normal
considerations that humanity will go
extinct within the next century uh
when when there may have been about that
200 billion people
and and not a 90 chance that maybe will
survive for a long time
and and millions a year will there will
be 200 trillion
um and corresponding now to the idea of
reaching into the urn and pulling out
ball number seven
in the case of the doomsday argument
you're supposed to consider your own
birth rank your own place in the uh
sequence of all humans who have been
born
and that is roughly number
100 billion that's more or less how many
humans have come before you
and so that just as in the urn case
we're pulling out such a low number
we're supposed to increase the
likelihood that there are only few balls
in the urns
so similarly here you having this
finding that you were born so early it's
supposed to increase the
likelihood that that the total number of
humans will be
200 billion rather than 200 trillion it
would kind of make you more
equitable if you are a number of roughly
100 billion out of 200 billion
is no big surprise about that whereas it
would kind of be
surprising and extraordinary to think
you were in in the very earliest
small fraction of one the first percent
of all humans
um that will ever have been born so so
that's the structure of the doomsday
argument
i think the critical part of that
is this idea that you should reason as
if you were a random sample from the set
of all
uh humans that will ever have existed
that's right but yeah
if if you do if you do accept that then
you know the rest
follows pretty straightforwardly but it
does seem i mean just
at glance and i to be very honest let me
put my own cards on the table i have
some
opinions about this kind of reasoning
but they're pretty mild
i go back and forth and i keep changing
my mind so i'm interested to see where
we go
here but clearly the point of view of
the
skeptic here is going to say how in the
world
can you reach any conclusions about the
far future
rate of humanity just without leaving
your armchair right i mean
this seems like you're you've sneaked in
some innocent seeming assumptions to do
a lot of heavy lifting
indeed yes so this was i think
the the universal reaction when the the
doomsday argument was
initially presented it originated uh
i think from um physicist
brandon carter uh and and then was kind
of written up by a philosopher john
leslie
in the 90s properly and put into this
patient framework
and most people thought i gotta be
something wrong with it
there's no way you could you know cut
through all the fog of vulnerability
about different future
risks of wars and new technologies and
all that and
derive this very striking conclusion
just from this very
seemingly very meager piece of evidence
um
but then when it came to trying to
explain what
what's wrong with the wind argument that
this agreement stopped
yeah and or many people were very
confident that i knew precisely what was
wrong with it but they all seem to have
a different
explanation um and and many of those
critiques and objections uh could
quite easily be seen to be flawed if
we try to apply the same kind of
critique to in other cases it would
produce uh absurd results so
it's actually quite tricky to if the
doom's argument is is false
it's non-trivial to display why it's
false right um
well maybe maybe you can explain a
little bit more um
and you can be judgey you can give your
own opinions here about this step that
says
i should reason as if i am a typical
randomly selected observer from the
history of all humankind i think that's
clearly the the place where we should
interrogate what's going on to maybe see
that we haven't sneaked something
in yeah so you might wonder why
why on earth would we think that i mean
it's not as if there were some
i don't know a time traveling stork that
sort of
picked up a human at random and then
drop them into
the year you were born so why why would
one believe something like that well
it seems that a methodological principle
similar to that is kind of necessary in
order to make a lot of
perfectly reasonable science work out so
i mean
in in your field of cosmology
these days what i call big world
hypotheses are are quite widely embraced
this would be hypothesis according to
which
the world uh is so big and
locally varied that you would expect uh
all possible observations to be made
by some observer somewhere yeah um
just if not for no other reason just
because of sort of
local thermal uh fluctuations you have
the boltzmann brains and you have
all kinds of local circumstances that
just by random accidents would be
different and if you have
an infinite or you know maybe to to
bracket
different issues that come up when we
talk about infinity is just an
enormously but still finitely large
universe you you wouldn't have
all these different theories that we
might have about cosmology and about the
value of different critical constants
um all of those theories predicting that
whatever you predict would in fact be
predicted
would would would in fact be observed
yeah let me i'll just say
very quickly i think that uh this just
just so everyone knows
this is an open question in cosmology i
mean there are absolutely
the possibilities on the table the
universe is infinite there's an infinite
number of observers of all different
kinds
and there's a possibility on the table
that the universe is finite and there's
not that many observers we just don't
know right now so
it's right it's important that by by
looking through the telescopes or
building big accelerators we can get
some useful evidence that potentially
could have some
bearing on these questions and without
introducing
some thing that looks a little bit like
this
typicality assumption i i call it a
self-sampling assumption the idea that
you should think of yourself
as though you were randomly sampled from
some
reference class it's very hard to see
how those
observational predictions uh
would be produced that you could then
test but if you have something like that
then you could say that
the vast majority of observers are
likely
to uh not um
be these weird rare uh
deluded freak observers who who
happen to see some extremely unusual
local fluctuation but most would be
typical and
and and then the theory predict that
that so
the theory that matches what we observe
uh would be one that said that what we
observe actually reflects the
typical conditions throughout the
universe and you can kind of then see
how you would be able to
connect these big world theories to
observation in
in in a way that seems kind of common
sensical
um alternatively you could try to argue
for this self-sampling assumption
by thinking instead of a simpler thought
experiment so
so just imagine that you have an you
start with an empty world
you have um 100
rooms cubicles and in each of these
100 cubicles you create one observer
and then on the outside you paint
maybe 90 of these rooms blue
and 10 red
and now you find yourself having been
created
in this world you're told about this
whole setup and you have to guess
what color is the room you are in at
some point you're going to exit the room
and you can find out that you answer
it seems very likely that in this case
you should set your
uh credence to your room being read
equal to
the fraction of all the observers um
that
are in red rooms this would match if
everybody bet this way you would
you know maximize your expected winnings
um and you could consider limiting cases
if instead of say 90
of the rooms being read what if 99
percent were what
as you approach the limit uh if all the
rooms were added you could just use
logic to deduce that your room is read
and it seems that the probability
should sort of gradually approach
probability one as
you move to a situation that is more and
more similar to
to the case where all the rooms are red
so so there are these different
um both scientific applications that
seem to require
the self-sampling assumption and also
these thought experiments
where it seems intuitively plausible
that that's the correct way of reasoning
i guess i i i'm on board with the second
one with the the thought experiment red
rooms the
the the uh then the worry is that that's
not a good analogy to the real world
i'm not sure i quite got the first one
there i mean
yes i can imagine cosmological scenarios
where there are many many um
observers um there seems to be a little
bit of an extra leap to say
and i should assume that i'm typical
within them or that there's some
properties that i'm i'm randomly sampled
from could you could you maybe say a
little bit more about this are you
claiming
that there is empirical evidence for
this kind of reasoning or just that it
is the only logical thing to do
um i'm saying that
it looks as though one needs this
methodological principle
in order to get the result that our
uh ordinary practice of trying to test
these different theories we have
makes sense so okay let's let's pick
something more specific so
the temperature of the cosmic background
uh at this stage of
cosmic evolution what is it 2.7 kelvin
or something yeah 2.74
right so that's what we think and we
think we have evidence for that in that
people have measured it and stuff like
that there's various observational data
um but now consider a different theory
it says that
actually the cosmic background is uh
3.1 kelvin so we think okay well that's
a possible theory we have strong reason
against it
but now suppose that we combine both of
these
hypotheses about the temperature of the
background with the claim that the
universe is so big that
whichever of these hypotheses is true
there will be some observers who
observe either value because locally
that would have been some statistical
fluctuation
in a sufficiently large universe there
will be sort of little bubbles where
the temperature just happens to be a bit
lower or higher
and so it looks then that
these two uh claims together
imply that there will exist some
observers who will see
who will measure a value of 2.7 kelvin
and and that will up
exist somewhere perverse who will
measure a value of 3.1
both the hypothesis that in general the
average value is 2.7 and the hypothesis
that the average value is 3.1 will
predict this
that there exists these observers who
make either observation so then the
question is
if they both say that both observations
were made what can we conclude from the
fact that uh well we've made this
observation
um of 2.7 it seems to be perfectly
consistent with both of these different
hypotheses and yet we think intuitively
it obviously favors the hypothesis
of 2.7 yeah okay
and so there i'm saying that well if you
and add in the
the methodological principle that we
should think most likely
our observation um is kind of what an
average observer a typical observer a
random observer would
that then then you get the probabilistic
inference to come through
and you can conclude that yeah it's
possible
the temperature is really 3.1 and we
were just this very rare
observer who saw something very unusual
but most likely with overwhelming
probability
the average temperature is 2.7 as indeed
we observe
because that's what almost all observers
would see if the real temperature were
actually 2.7 i guess there's a tiny bit
of daylight here between
this way of casting it and what i think
is the traditional
cosmologist way of casting it and to be
honest let me be very clear
as as a cosmologist i know that typical
cosmologists are not philosophically
very sophisticated and they don't think
about these things too hard they just
get the right answer and move on with
their lives
but there's the way of saying um
you're casting it as sort of if the
universe were very very large and there
were lots of observers and we were a
typical observer in that ensemble
whereas i think most physicists would
just say let's imagine we're at a
typical place
in the universe uh regardless of how
many observers there are right even if
the universe
is not that much bigger than what we can
observe
in our horizon do you think that's an
important difference or
basically the math works out to be the
same in in those two justifications
well i think uh there is an important
uh difference in principle i think as
it it it might for various applications
kind of come out to more or less the
same result
um if you think that
observers are sufficiently you know
uniformly distributed
yeah but if you have a different
application where
you're trying to evaluate
different hypotheses say about where
observers are like if you think about
the galaxy
and where there would likely be uh
planets
conducive for the evolution of
intelligent life
and so on then right um then then it
could start to be important that you
focus not
on spatial temporal regions but actually
on counting
observers it could be more likely that
you would find yourself
within a certain small region of space
time
which is dense say in planets likely to
create
intelligent life then with it's a much
larger reading of space time
where observers would be more scarce
okay i mean i know that uh to get back
to the doomsday argument because
i do i want to be i know that
philosophers like to like list all the
possibilities but i want to at some
point actually
get an argument that one is correct or
incorrect there is uh there's another
counter argument not just saying we're
not typical observers but there's a
counter argument that says
well if your two scenarios are
200 billion people or 200 trillion
people in the history of humanity
uh because there are more observers in
one of those scenarios
i should i'm more likely to be in that
universe i should sort of
give that theory a boost in my prior
probability
just because there are more observers
there and that sort of cancels out the
fact that i'm
early on uh and therefore even though
i'm unlikely to be early in that big
universe that
the universe is also more likely and
therefore i can say nothing
about which of these two universes i
live in yeah and
that is one of the uh
most important possible responses to the
priestly argument
and this initial idea that i
uh explained earlier the idea that you
should think of yourself as a random
sample from
from all the observers that exist in in
some reference class
i call that a self-sampling assumption
and what
you just mentioned is what i would call
the stealth
indication assumption and it's roughly
the idea that
the very fact that you find yourself
existing you have been born into the
world it gives you
evidence that a lot of observers
probably exist in this world in in some
sense it's as if that would then have
been sort of more slots for you to have
been born
into it right and as you men as you say
that
yeah it does turn out that if you do
accept this self-indication assumption
then
that exactly cancels out
the uh probability shift that the
doomsday argument says we should make
in favor of there being fewer it's like
you you first
register the fact oh i exist that gives
me
increased evidence that probably there
will be a lot of people existing
by the self-indication assumption then
you notice oh i'm really early
that makes it more likely that i will be
a fewer observer in the future but those
two
shifts exactly um cancel out
um so so that that has that neat feature
you get rid of the doomsday argument in
one fell swoop
and and that might in fact be the
strongest argument for the
self-indication assumption
um it does have some counterintuitive
implications of its own though uh
so there is um what i
call the presumptuous philosopher
thought experiment
i love that phrase by the way i give you
i i use that in many many talks and
and writings because i really think it
captures something that we should be
worried about so uh so please explain
what it is
well it's the idea that
uh it seems somewhat of an open question
at the moment
whether the universe is finite or
infinite or
i mean if it's finite than just how big
it is we we know it's very big but is it
like
very very big or very very very big
uh that seems like something you can't
just
sit and answer in your armchair you have
to actually you know
build cosmological models and
measure the expansion speed and try to
evaluate inflationary cosmologies and
but if you accept the self-indication
assumption it does seem like you would
have overwhelmingly strong evidence
um for concluding that out of two
hypotheses one of which postulate
that there are many orders of magnitude
more observer
that that hypothesis is true so
um so consider one one hype support
universe
is is finite but uh yeah now in in
according to one hypothesis there are
trillion trillion
observers and uh on arrival hypothesis
there are a trillion trillion trillion
observers
and let's suppose the physicists say
well this is like interesting the super
duper symmetry considerations show that
one of these two possibilities is true
and now we just need to run this
experiment and it will definitively tell
us which
which of these is correct and and we
just need
i suppose you just need twenty thousand
dollars to build this very simple
machine
like a trivial thing in comparison to
right and if somebody's philosopher says
no no no no it's not worth wasting 20
000 dollars i can just tell you what the
answer is of course it's the trillion
trillion trillion
observer hypothesis that's true that's a
trillion times more likely
than the other one by the cell
indication assumption comes directly out
of the self-indication assumption
and so the objection is that we don't
really
accept that it just seems like crazy
that i mean
about as crazy as the idea that you
could uh rule out
hypotheses where the human species will
last for a very long time just by
reflecting on your birth rank
so here instead you're ruling out
hypotheses where there are slightly
fewer but still a huge number of people
in the universe
just by uh considering the fact that you
exist it also seems a little bit like an
overreach
so um good so it does seem like
in either case it's just be super duper
clear because i know that when i was
learning this this
this all confused me uh very quickly so
the two options on the table
are you know give theories prior
probabilities
by how elegant or reasonable they seem
and then within each theory assume
you're a typical observer
and then the other is assume you're a
typical observer
but boost those theories that have a lot
of observers
in their prior probabilities because
observers like you are more likely to
appear there
and you're making the argument that
either one of these seems to give
us leverage uh over the world that goes
beyond what we
should be able to get sitting from our
armchair so what is your recommendation
i mean
what how should we think about these
questions
well i'm i'm i'm i kind of
reluctant to embrace either of these and
uh i mean and what you found uh a lot in
the in the
early literature on this uh i mean when
people were starting to discuss the
doomsday argument is that they would
usually
just pick one of these alternatives or
rather usually they would reinvent it
not realizing that other people
and then i would kind of just be either
ignore the kind of argument
on the other side or be oblivious to it
and they would just feel very pleased
so they might invent the self-indication
assumption and say ha
i've refuted the doomsday argument but
then not try to address or
reflect on on the fact that it on its
own have these other
counter-intuitive implications um
so i mean i think it's unclear what we
should do
i mean it certainly seems worth
exploring whether they're from third
alternative
um so you could kind of say that
the self-indication assumption says
think of yourself as a random sample
from
all possible observers whereas the
self-sampling assumption said
think of yourself as a random sample
from all actual observers that exist
yeah um but maybe what you should do is
to say
think of yourself as a random sample
from
all actual observers within from
reference class that
might not be identical to the set of all
obstacles like
maybe maybe you don't need to think of
yourself as random examples from all
observers including ones that will exist
far into the future if humanity survives
but maybe from some
somewhat narrower class of observer um
so for example if you think these future
humans they would be very different from
us maybe they will be post-human
they will be they'll certainly be in an
epistemically very different situation
from i mean they will know for
among other things that that the human
species survived the 21st century and so
so maybe they will be so different that
we shouldn't think of ourselves now as a
random sample from some set that
includes
those maybe they're just too different
from us just as we don't think of
ourselves as a random sample from
all physical objects that includes rocks
and
um and and windows and
trees like with if you do that then i
mean then you would block the doomsday
argument you say well
we can't rule out these futures where
there's going to be a lot of future
observers as long as we say they are
different from us in in in such a way
that they fall
outside our reference class um
you could try to go down a path like
that um
and i i mean in in my doctoral
dissertation back back in the 90s
uh where i developed a theory of
philanthropics i i
i explored the possibility of whether
you could relativize the reference class
so that different observers should use
different reference classes
and think of themselves as if they were
a random sample
from some different reference classes
depending on which observer it was and
which time it was
and it might then be possible to avoid
both the
uh counterintuitive implications like
the doomsday argument and
the ones like the presumptuous
philosophers that come if you
accept the self-indication assumption
well my own
i'm what i'm tempted to think and i
haven't really completely nailed this
down myself yet
is that maybe we're just it's just a
mistake to think of ourselves as typical
observers
in some class that is much bigger than
me
in other words you know i i know a lot
of things
about my non-typicality already like
most people
are not theoretical physicists you know
there's plenty of obvious ways in which
i'm not a typical observer
and maybe i should judge cosmological
scenarios on the likelihood that
observers exactly like me should arise
but not go beyond that at all and
therefore draw no conclusions on the
basis of how many
alien life forms or post-humans that
might exist
so that i think is too narrow
so if if we go back to the example of
the
cosmic background whether it's 2.7
or 3.1 kelvin so
on on both of these hypotheses we
uh imagine in a big enough world there
would be some observers who would be
seeing 2.7 when they run some
measurements
yeah um and that would be some that
would be seeing 3.1
but if you only included in your
reference
class observers who were exactly uh like
you in the same mental state with the
same evidence then that would only
include ones that saw 2.7
since that's what you are seeing right
yeah so
uh in that case it would be true that
on both of these different theories that
2.7
theory under 3.1 100 of all the
observers
in that reference class would be seeing
2.7
well right but it but i'm suggesting
that we can uh
judge theories on the basis of whether
or not the likelihood that they predict
any observers that would predict that
would see exactly that already like i
would in other words it's sort of the
old evidence versus new evidence
uh issue like i i don't want to forget
that i already know
an observer who sees uh the cmb with
2.7 degrees i can judge theories in the
basis of whether there should be people
like me
in them but uh i i can't say that those
people
are typical right but so in this case
both of these theories uh predict that
there would be people seeing 2.7 uh
impact predicted with probability i'm
sorry yes i i
right so you're comparing maybe maybe i
misunderstood there's a
sort of a small universe where the
universe is 2.7 everywhere
and a large universe in which the univer
the cmb is usually 3.1 but in some
places it's 2.7 is that what we're
comparing
yeah or compared to large universes
where the average temperature
is in one is 2.7 and the average
temperature
in the other is 3.1 but both are large
enough that there would be pockets
of different temperatures right
big world theories predict that there
will be some observers seeing
2.7 some seeing 3.1 what i disagree
about is kind of what the average
observer or the vast majority of
observers will see
that's right so i think the bullet i
would like to bite is in those cases
where both universes are big enough
that even though the averages are
different they're it
it is very likely that an observer just
like me
exists in both of them i cannot judge
between them that's what i
would actually uh accept that conclusion
that that seems to be the least
presumptuous thing i can do
yeah except i think um
i think the universe probably is like
that
i think that all of these i mean yeah
uh different finite sized brains and
brain states
that that humans could occupy are
instantiated
uh and i still believe that we have um
that we gain some useful information
about
the layout of our universe from from
doing astronomy
yeah no i think i think that's true
actually i mean let me let me steer the
conversation that direction a little bit
because
uh in the philosophy literature we have
these discussions about the future of
humanity
and boltzmann brains and stuff like that
but the down-to-earth working
cosmologists
some of them do appeal to anthropic
reasoning to
explain for example uh the value of
the cosmological constant uh or other
parameters that we observe you know the
fine tuning
of the fine structure constant that
allows for
atoms in chemistry and life do you think
that this kind of reasoning
uh do you think that the working
scientists who use that kind of
anthropic reasoning are on the right
track
yeah well i mean you have to look at the
application by application but
the uh the general idea that you might
initially be
puzzled by the apparent fine-tuning of
our universe that
there are a number of different
parameters and
constants that seem to have values that
permit
intelligent life to uh exist obviously
but also to be thought that had the
value been very different
no observers would have existed it would
just have been a
highly diluted hydrogen gas or or some
other
degenerate state that i think it's a
right to initially be struck by that
that's like huh that's kind of
weird yeah and also to recognize that
um one possible explanation of that is
uh
that there is an ensemble of universal
with a wide
distribution of different parameter
values
instantiated within that ensemble
and then apply anthropic reasoning to
say that this ensemble theory
nevertheless predicts that what we
should observe is this
apparently very fine-tuned universe um
where the fine-tuning is kind of
apparent in in that the ensemble as a
whole
ideally would not need to be very
fine-tuned and nevertheless would
find themselves in the universe that was
fine-tuned and that would then
constitute an explanation
for for the fine-tuning that we seem to
see i i think that
line of reasoning is basically sound do
you think that we can go beyond that
to actually say to make a calculation
and a prediction i mean the thing that
uh
stephen weinberg for example tried to do
back in the 80s with the cosmos
constant was to say uh let's imagine
there is a smooth distribution of values
of the cosmological constant
and the value affects how many galaxies
are produced therefore let's ask
uh what an average observer might see
and he
predicted more or less the right value
or are you are you on board with uh
by the right value i mean the value that
was empirically discovered 10 years
later so
do you think that's a kind of valid
inference
um yeah so it i
i i think that there is
a piece of methodology that is needed in
order to
go from some theory about what exists
what galaxies there are out there and
what planets and what observer
to go from some kind of objective model
of the world
to some observational prediction yeah
about what you or i are likely to see um
and this is where the anthropics comes
in as this little piece of methodology
that tries to bridge that gap
um
in a sense it's a methodology about how
to reason about
indictable information yeah that is
information that has to do with
uh where you are what time it is
who you are um as as opposed to the kind
of
objective structure about um
what exists uh and so
that kind of methodology can then be
used in combination with different
hypotheses about
the objective structures out there to
derive different
uh predictions that that we can test
can we make sorry now go ahead
i mean can we make uh aside from the
cosmos constant in cosmological things
um
can we use this kind of reasoning in
your view to reason about the existence
of intelligent civilizations elsewhere
the fermi paradox kind of thing
um yeah well so
i've always thought that
the fermi paradox is not very
paradoxical um
we don't see any signs of
intelligent uh life
that's true but i don't know what
i mean for there to be a paradox there
has to be some sort of
argument for x and then some other
argument for not x that both seem
persuasive and then we are left with
this
conflict that we don't know how to
resolve but but here it just seems that
there is
uh an argument for one we haven't seen
any aliens but i'm not sure what the
argument would be
that we should be surprised uh about
that i mean we certainly know that there
are a lot of planets
yeah but that doesn't mean there was a
high likelihood
that alias would result i mean because
there are a lot of step
between having a planet and and having
life
let alone intelligent life and for all
we know
uh those steps might be very improbable
or there might be one improbable step
um so maybe just going even to the
simplest replicators maybe that just
required
an astronomical coincidence that the
right amino acids might
like a hundred of them might just have
to have bumped into each other in
precisely the right way to
to create something that could get
self-replication going
for what we know uh in in in
biochemistry that that's
that's perfectly possible that that
could be such an improbable step
now you might then say well it's
something we should be very reluctant to
do to postulate something that
improbable
because we exist and i was going to say
that yeah
became the improbable then our equipment
seems to conflict with that story
but so that's where this anthropics
would come in well
it would if there was only one planet
right and we existed on that planet that
would be evidence
against the idea that there were some
extremely improbable steps
in evolutionary history but
if there are gazillions of planets and
only the one where intelligent life are
in the end observed then it might not be
so surprising that we find ourselves on
a planet where impellant life observed
even if there are some extremely
improbable steps in going from
one planet to intelligent life
um if there are enough planets it's like
enough lottery tickets it's not
surprising you win the lottery
even if any every ticket has only a one
in a million chance of winning
if you bought 10 million lottery tickets
right okay okay so i mean that uh
i'm actually very sympathetic to that
point of view i think that people
tend to say well there's a lot of
planets
and how small could the probability of
life forming be
and you know the answer could be it
could be really really small
yeah it could be really small the drake
equation must be one of the most over
hyped we know because it gives this
appearance of some
rigorous scientific grasp yeah that you
can use to calculate how many aliens
there are but then they're like
some some parameter values there that we
are not just uncertain about but
uh the value might be one
a hundred percent probability or it
might be ten to the power of
minus a thousand uh we just have no clue
but you seem uh yeah and i saw i
completely 100 agree with that but you
do seem
more sympathetic to the doomsday
argument kind of reasoning
than to the the presumptuous philosopher
that follows from the self-indication
assumption the the boosting that we
would give to theories with lots of
observers
so is there some combination of
doomsday-like arguments
and uh there's no other aliens out there
that seem highly technologically
advanced
empirical uh observation that lets us
conclude
wow we're probably doomed we're probably
going to destroy ourselves within a few
generations
well i mean it gets complicated i mean
just just to be clear i mean i think
there are eight areas out there i just
think they're
like far away uh so i mean if you're
infinite then certainly that would be
aliens out there right uh
but maybe not within our light cone um
um yeah i mean so the doomsday argument
is kind of
counterintuitive and surprising but
maybe you could sort of persuade
yourself to
accept it there is a thought experiment
that
has the same structure as the doomsday
argument but maybe it
takes the counter-intuitiveness one
level up
so consider uh
what i call the adam and eve thought
experiments so imagine that
the world uh was uh
created and that there were initially uh
two people adam and eve um
and then whether there were gonna be
additional people whether there was
gonna be a whole human race
coming into existence at the leader time
maybe depends on the choices that adam
and eve makes and so let's say that they
have
uh they might be
tempted by carnal desire um
they were we know from the books that
they were so yeah
but let's suppose that they thought uh
if we do create a whole race of humans
uh that would be very bad um
that that we were not supposed to do
that and
so we definitely would not want to
create billions of humans that we might
know that that would be the inevitable
result if
if eve has a child as a result of
of our sin uh but we're not sure i mean
obviously they they could
uh carnally embrace and it might he
might not get pregnant right
but i might think let's suppose it's one
in pan pants that she would
bear a child as a result based on just
normal facts about the human
reproductive system
um so they say well it's not worth it's
not worth risking it 10
of creating this disaster we are not
going to do it but now let's suppose
there's this snake that
slithers up and whispers
well okay so you're either going to be
come pregnant or not
if you carnally embrace uh but
really think about what the chances are
if you do become pregnant then you would
be the first out of billions and
billions of humans
an extraordinarily unusual position
in the uh distribution of all observers
and by the self-sampling assumption
the probability that you would be the
first to
if there were going to be billions of
humans would be what
well uh one in in several billion
yeah extremely improbable so when you
conditionalize
on the fact that you were among the
first two you can basically disregard
that hypothesis
and uh conversely if uh
if it doesn't get pregnant you would be
completely normal you would be the first
two out of two people probably
one so updating on this then they could
become extremely confident that
this act would not produce what seems
intuitively like they should think would
have about the 10
chance of resulting uh that that seems
counteractive
you could go further let's suppose that
adam is a bit lazy he doesn't want to go
out hunting
and he thinks it would be really
convenient if like a wounded deer
just happened to limp by the cave in in
the next
10 minutes uh you know save him a lot of
effort
so then it seems he could form the the
firm
intention that if a wounded there
does not appear
they will produce offspring and
that will then go on to create billions
of people
and then suddenly he would then have
strong evidence uh to be fully convinced
that a wounded deer would appear and
that also it seemed kind of hard to
think that that would be the rational
thing for him to
to believe um so i i think those are
maybe even more counterintuitive
consequences of accepting their self
sampling assumption
okay then reference class so and
therefore
we should not accept it well it
it certainly would count against
accepting it right now
you have to then look at what the
alternatives are if you don't accept it
what do you do then do you accept the
self indication assumption
well then from just philosopher do you
instead go down the path maybe of
relativizing the reference class like i
was alluding to earlier
maybe although that also you know
has its own possible problems
um and in general i think it's an area
where there is still some
murkiness and on clarity um okay i think
it goes quite deep
at these methodological questions um
and and we don't get it it might be that
one of these answers is correct but
i'm not sure we have understood enough
yet to be justifiably very confident
in any of them okay that that makes
perfect sense so in other words
for specifically for the doomsday
argument um
it's something we should think about and
and maybe be worried about and maybe
found
institutes to to try to avoid doomsday
but uh it's not like a good idea
independently yeah
yeah but you don't think that we
understand it uh
well enough to just say yes that's the
correct conclusion
uh that's right okay very good but uh
but i can't let you get away without you
know saying we can extend
this idea of self-sampling of typicality
among
the sense of all observers you have
famously said well
let's include in the set of all
observers that we might be typical among
uh observers that are being simulated by
some higher level intelligence and uh
live their whole lives out in a computer
so that leads us to
the simulation argument is that right
yeah
so yeah why don't you tell us what let's
imagine that there are people it's
unlikely but they're people in the
audience who don't know what the
simulation argument is
um well
the uh the simulation argument
tries to show that one of three
possibilities
obtains and
one of those is that there is a very
strong convergence where virtually all
civilizations that
are current stage of technological
development go extinct before they reach
technological maturity um
so that's one possibility something that
could be true
a second a possibility is that there's a
very strong
convergence amongst all uh
technologically mature civilizations in
that they all lose
interest in creating
computer simulations with conscious
people and tester simulations
um if you want and the third possibility
is that
we are almost certainly living in a
computer simulation
and um so the argument involves some
from simple probability theory and stuff
but the basic idea is
is a very possible to grab just
intuitively which is supposed that the
third possibility does not obtain so at
least some
civilizations at our current stage
eventually reach technological and
maturity
even if it's just one in a thousand um
and suppose the second possibility also
does not appear so at least
uh some some some reasonable fraction of
those who do become technologically
mature still are interested in using
some
like non-trivial fraction of the
resources to creating ancestor
simulations
that you can then tell that there would
be many many more people
like us living in simulations than
would be have lived in in original
history just
just because if you estimate the amount
of compute power
uh that the mature civilization would
have and you compare that to estimates
of the cost of creating
simulations of conscious beings like
humans you just see that
even by devoting a tiny fraction of one
percent of their compute power for just
like one minute
that they could create thousands and
thousands of rounds of all of human
history
um and so if you reject the first two uh
possibilities
you are then forced to conclude that the
vast majority of people with our
experiences are simulated
and then i claim conditional on that we
would think we are probably one of the
simulated ones
the anthropic stuff comes in only in
this third last step
in going from most people with our kind
of experiences are simulated
to therefore we are probably simulated
right uh so and you and you buy this
this is one that you're well
willing to stand behind this argument uh
yeah
right and so okay i'm so because of that
let me just push back on it a little bit
i'm very open-minded about this i'm
agnostic i really don't know
um can you say a little bit more about
uh how we know how much compute power it
takes to effectively
simulate a reasonable consciousness i
mean i can at least imagine that we
understand
once we understand better what that
would take uh if we understand you know
the efficiency of the brain etc
uh we could argue that
to truly simulate uh
human consciousness requires almost as
many
uh atoms as a brain has of order of
magnitude uh and
you you're clearly assuming it takes a
lot less
yeah a lot less so we have to i guess
first um
be clear on what the success criterion
is for
having successfully created one of these
ancestor simulations
so it's not that you would create
a simulation that behaved exactly like
the original
in as much as every microscopic behavior
would be captured perfectly and and you
could use it as a perfectly reliable
predictive model
there might be all kinds of random
stochastic events in human brains that
with via butterfly effects eventually
have big
implications on our behavior yeah like
maybe and
a single elementary particle move you
know one planck
length might a day later make you say
something different than you would
otherwise have said
uh but it's rather that it's close
enough that you couldn't tell from the
inside
whether you were the simulated one or
the uh
the the non-simulated one right um
and so to do that i think it would be
sufficient
to capture a
human uh mental uh phenomena
at the computational level
more or less something that would have
maybe
neurons and and maybe synapses
and then the properties of the synapse
might
be represented by some
reasonably sized vector like a thousand
values to represent the signups but
certainly i think that would go down to
having to keep track of where every atom
is
at any given point in time or anything i
think that would be vast overkill
okay there are different ways you could
come at it as well you could look for
example
uh yeah if if you have um
estimates of the human brain's
processing power estimates of say our
sensory perception like how high
resolution does the screen have to be
for
us not to protect pixels and um
um
you could at another kind of line of
argument for why this could be
feasible to do is you could like
creating
so in a sense you would have to not just
create the the simulate the brains right
but also some sort of environment for
them
to experience and you might think that
would be hard but then
you think even our own humble little
three-pound
organic brains managed every night to
create
a kind of virtual reality stimulation
that sometimes seem pretty uh realistic
to to the person dreaming and like if
they
if if they can do it like without
training then presumably a
post-human civilization with planetary
sized
uh nano computers
would be able to do this without
breaking a threat
yeah no i'm on board with the
environment i think you can trick people
uh into thinking their environment is
realistic with rather low
uh amounts of sensory input but it's the
brain and the connect home
i'm less sure about i mean we have 85
billion neurons and they're connected in
complicated ways and so
i guess i'm just a little um wary
when people i think people leap a little
bit too easily into imagining how easy
it would be
to simulate a human consciousness i mean
one of the
i didn't want to bring this up but one
of the other ways the argument could
fail is if it's just impossible
to simulate human consciousness on a
computer i think that we're both on the
side that
it shouldn't be but there are definitely
people who would disagree right
uh there are yeah i mean so the
simulation argument
assumes i call the substrate
independence thesis yeah which
a lot of the people accept i mean i
think in philosophy of mind and
amongst computer scientists and
physicists i think majority opinion
would be
that what's necessary for a conscious
phenomena
to arise is not that some specific
material
is being used like carbon atom
but rather that there is a certain
structure of a computation that has to
be performed
yeah um so i mean the the paper
in which i presented the simulation
argument just makes that assumption
sure okay um and then you can look for
arguments for that
uh elsewhere in the literature uh yeah
so i do
still worry that uh simulating
consciousness is harder than we think
even though it should be in principle
possible but the other worry i have is
that
uh if i take seriously the
some version of the self-sampling
assumption i just i just say some
version because i'm
unclear on what version it would be not
because it is intrinsically unclear but
uh is isn't there a prediction then that
you would make
that uh since it's easier to do low
resolution simulations than higher
resolution ones
uh most observers should find themselves
living in the lowest possible resolution
simulations the clunkiest versions of
reality
well it the kind of two sides to the
equation
so there is the cost of a simulation
and other things equal yes the lower
the cost of running a particular
simulation the more of those simulations
you'd expect to be run
but the the other side is the the
benefit like that's like
the people creating the simulations
might have different reasons for
creating them
and it might be that some of those
reasons maybe the most common reasons
would require
something more than the minimal level of
resolution
and then you have most observers of our
kind living
in uh higher than the minimal level of
resolution simulations
yeah maybe i don't know i mean i think
that when when we start doing these
simulations uh
we'll start doing them at pretty low
resolution i think it becomes a little
fuzzy
to me uh once we think of the
practicalities
of actually doing this so so that's why
i am
agnostic about it but you would you
would go so far as to say you think that
we probably are in a simulation right
now
i tend to pond on that question
[Laughter]
pregnant pause
if the trick journalists sometimes have
by just saying nothing for a while you
usually get the subject to kind of say
more than they wanted to say but i'm not
falling for it
well okay i mean it's it is uh
but that's fine i will let you punt on
it but let's
you know get on onto the record the idea
that um
we can't punt forever right you know the
the idea behind these arguments is that
we're they're supposed there's supposed
to be a right or wrong version of them
and
and i'm very happy to sort of punt um
you know uh uh provisionally say well we
just don't know yet
but uh presumably it's knowable i mean
how should we
get better at this how should we figure
it out yeah well i mean so so i believe
in the simulation
argument in that uh the disjunction
between these three
hypotheses then the question arises
how should we apportion our credence
between these three alternatives and i
mean more than one of them could be true
yeah um and
i mean as a first cut it seems uh
we have quite a lot of uncertainty about
these matters in general so probably
each one of them should have some
non-trivial amount of probability
um beyond that though i mean
that doesn't imply they should each have
exactly a third probability
you might kind of think one of them
deserves the alliance here
that then becomes a a more uh
a less clear-cut issue where the
original simulation argument is silent
and you need to bring in some additional
evidence or arguments or
speculations um which which i think yeah
one one definitely wants to do but then
one takes like a step beyond the
original simulation
argument i guess let me put it this way
are there
predictions you would make on the basis
of the uh
hypothesis that we live in a simulation
are there things that we
should expect to see about reality if
that were true
well so if we conditionalize on the
stimulation hypothesis
yeah that we are in the simulation then
does that have any
observational consequences any
predictions following from that
yeah and i think yes but they are kind
of probabilistic in nature
so to start with i think there are
certain
possible observations that would be
extremely uh
low probability otherwise that at least
like become conceivable
if we are in the simulation mr take
something trivial so if you are in a
simulation you could imagine a window
popping up in front of you at some point
saying
yeah you click you're in simulation
click here for more information
that would be extremely strong evidence
for the simulation hypothesis
yeah other things like say
an afterlife might seem if if we are in
a naturalistic world
not simulated uh that that
that would be more of a stretch uh in a
simulation it seems like a perfectly
uh natural thing that may or may not
depending on just
how the simulation is set up and what
the simulators have in mind but there
would be no impediment to
running the same mind repeatedly in
different simulations or environments
another type of implication would be via
the simulation argument itself so if the
simulation argument is right
that at least one of these three
possibilities is true
then if we get evidence that the
simulation hypothesis that the third
hypothesis is true that might then
uh lower the probability of the other
two hypotheses they
right we've already satisfied the
requirements that
at least one of them is true and so the
others might still be true but that
would be less reason to believe it so
the probability of those might go up
then yeah you might
predict as well that further insight
into i don't know neuroscience and and
uh hardware design and nanotech would
tend to uh not reveal information
suggesting that
simulations are infeasible to build
um that doesn't follow with logical
necessity because you could imagine that
the simulation would have a different
physics than the universe in which the
computer running the simulation
nevertheless i think that would be
another thing's equal
uh implication in that direction um
and and a whole host of other maybe more
uh fanciful possibilities as well that
just seemed kind of hard to reconcile
if we live in basement level physical
reality uh
in in a simulation you could imagine the
simulators acting
uh more or less like pods able to
intervene
and shape in in ways that might
not make sense if you were thinking of
the universe as just this blind equation
of
evolving uh particles according to some
simple
differential equations but but if you
thought of it as being interactive with
that system and then some kind of
intelligent purposeful uh
designer slash whatever role they are
playing that was kind of interacting
with this then
it might make it uh less unlikely that
that would be
um yeah
phenomena that that that they might
introduce into the world
uh that that that that would otherwise
be
kind of weird well could we talk to them
could we attract their attention somehow
you know i mean i figure
uh typically when we do simulations of
large scale structure in the universe we
don't necessarily pay attention to what
every single particle in the mesh
is doing and likewise they probably
don't pay attention to every single
planet
uh among the billions of billions in uh
our observable universe so
would it be wise or possible to uh you
know raise our hand a little bit and say
hey simulators we we've reached
self-consciousness why don't you say hi
yeah um i mean the cost of keeping track
of what we are doing would be i think
small compared to the cost of running
the simulation in the first place
so uh i think in a wide range of
scenarios they would be
uh easily able to monitor and see
whatever the most significant things
that were coming out of human civil
possibly everything that like i might
keep track of every thought
then it depends on the purpose of this
right that like
whether this information would be
relevant for what they were doing or
which game for me
um well it's good to think about i mean
i i like uh
whether or not i uh believe it i do
think that it is an option we should
keep on the table and maybe
i don't know if it affects how we act in
the world but uh
you know it definitely is something that
uh
you know cosmological uh thinkers
should have is one of their things on
the table and it leads
to i think you know the last topic i
want to get to just very quickly is uh
you've been talking recently
about artificial intelligence and uh
certainly i would imagine that if you if
you grant that
we could in principle simulate pretty
convincingly
uh human or human-like intelligence then
why not have things that are similar but
different
you know completely artificial
intelligences maybe ones that are
much smarter than us and so you wrote
the provocatively
titled book super intelligence um you
know what should be
we've had some talk on the podcast
already with people like stuart russell
uh and max tag mark but you know what
should the person on the street keep in
mind
about the prospects for truly super
intelligent ai
uh yeah i mean i think it's it's coming
unless we sort of managed to destroy
ourselves
before by some other means which
unfortunately cannot be
completely ruled out but um
since the book came out i think
progress in ai has been
quite impressive um and things seems to
be coming together
and so what the book really tries to do
though is not so much
describe the the current state of place
play in ai or or predict the timelines i
mean there's like one or two chapters in
the beginning but
the book really then focused on the
dynamics that would
arise if and when you do attain
something comparable to human level of
general intelligence
uh in machines and i argue that you
would probably then
fairly shortly thereafter have super
intelligence things that
radically at performance
across all cognitive domains and that
if you think about the implications of
having machine superintelligence it
really would be the last inventions
we'd ever need to make in as much as
this super intelligence wouldn't be much
better
at inventing and you would get the kind
of telescoping of
the future so all of those science
fiction-like technologies that maybe
humanity would produce if we had 20
000 years of working on the problem
maybe we will have
you know perfectly realistic virtual
realities have colonies on on
on mars and we'd have cures for aging
and
all kinds of other things that these are
consistent with the laws of physics just
very hard to do but if you had this
science and technology uh being
developed at
super intelligent time scales then all
of those things might happen quickly so
so this
what otherwise might seem like a far
future could happen quite
uh shortly after you have super
intelligence and and all in all then
this
seems to make this maybe the most
important translation
uh in in all of human history
um such that if you think that there's
even some you know reasonable
probability this
this may happen you know in our lifetime
let's say then that that should make it
a very high priority to
to better understand it and in
particular to see whether there are
things we could do to
increase the chances that that things
will go well in
this transition to the machine
intelligence era
and so a lot of the work that that i've
been doing
and other researchers here at the the
institute
have focused on ai both working on some
technical issues related to ai alignment
how to design algorithms that
would make it possible to get like
arbitrarily smart systems to actually
understand human goals and value and
uh and and and play some beneficial role
and also
um at the governance uh
level thinking about how the world might
then assuming we solve the alignment
problem
um increase the chances that this
powerful technology
is used for some beneficial purpose
rather than
to wage war against one another or
oppress one another
um and a bunch of ethical questions as
well that
that arise when we are starting to think
about the possibility of uh
advanced digital minds we had an
interesting conversation on the podcast
with uh john danaher about
automation and uh what it means for
employment going forward and you know
his argument was that robots will
basically
take over essentially all of our jobs
and that's a good thing
uh you think that super intelligent ai
will
help us solve the problem of needing to
work for a living is is there sort of an
economic and social structure
angle to this kind of stuff yeah yeah i
mean that that
that that would happen uh certainly for
all their jobs
that are kind of functionally defined
um so
i mean if you think about the job of of
of uh
being an olympic athlete or something
like that
um say you're using bald and you can run
faster than anybody else and you get
paid for doing that
it doesn't directly follow that he would
lose
his job even if we could create like a
bipedal machine that can run faster
because
in in a sense the task is intrinsically
defined
in terms of a human doing certain things
we might just have a basic preference
for certain
things being done by human um
you know just as you might some people
pay extra for some products to be made
by hand rather than by machine or be
made by indigenous people
or some favored group um
but setting aside uh those types of jobs
than the others
yeah i think once you have artificial
general intelligence at
the broadly human level you could
automate a whole bunch of them and and
the rest when you also sort out
the the robotics part of it
uh which i think yeah you'd you'd be
able to
do most of the things that humans need
their bodies to
to do find motoric control and stuff
with
um you see i i think
the ai part is kind of the the key part
in robotics as well
and you could get by with a fairly
clunky robotic body
if you had enough intelligence to
operate it
well yeah i mean okay there's clearly
many many things we could talk about
here but uh let me just i have a final
question
uh fairly open-ended so you can choose
what
uh you where what direction you want to
go in but you are the director of the
future of humanity institute
so i have to ask you about what you
actually would predict for the future of
humanity
what i would like to say is what do you
think things are going to be like 50
years from now but i'll let you uh
choose whatever time scale you're most
comfortable talking about
yeah so um i
we often try to i think separate out
that
the time scale questions from the other
questions
so some of the things one might be
thinking about
with respect to the future can kind of
be
uh explored without making specific
assumptions about when they will happen
you could for example say
if and when you might say that there's
this
set of technological capacities they
look like they
are physically possible there is some
trajectory that eventually
will be there we are not sure how long
it will take
but we might be able to say that if and
when we do get those capabilities
here is a bunch of things that would
enable us to do and and one might then
think about how that would
play out strategically how it would
interact with other things
yeah okay um so i find it like
if you take some some intermediate time
scale like a few decades i find it very
hard to predict what the world would be
like then because there are certain
radically transformative technological
developments that i think will happen
uh i don't think that will happen next
year i do think that will happen within
the next hundred years
but if you're asking me in 20 years i'm
kind of that's
very unsure whether say the ai
revolution would have happened by then
or not so
i would be then in an epistemic
superposition
regarding what the world would look like
then but that doesn't mean
i have no opinions it just means that
they kind of bifurcate into two broad
classes of uh
scenarios well i think i think that's
fair i mean i think let's let's put the
time scale aside i mean are there
what what are the sort of conceptual
changes you would most want to have
people be appreciative of when they
think about what the future will bring
well i guess the most important might be
the meta level one
but it is a topic um
about which it's possible to
think hard and do better or worse like i
think traditionally
the future has been a more
it's been a free-for-all it's like you
sort of feel like i think people feel
they can
uh just make stuff up you can relax
it's like the land of fantasy and fancy
and
it's almost like a projection screen
where we can display our hopes and fears
and
and tell some morality tale but but
actually trying to get it right
i i think that just hasn't been the
driver of much
uh thinking up until more recently and
now
and over the last you know next couple
of decades that has actually started to
be developed a set of
concepts and and that that enable us to
start structure our thinking about the
future
i think in in a much deeper and more
incisive way and and our little
we don't have all the pieces but we have
some important pieces we've actually
covered
a few of them in our conversation i
think the simulation argument
is one of these pieces a clue it doesn't
tell us exactly what would happen but it
narrows down
the range of possibilities to three i
mean if you accept it right there's the
doomsday argument which may or may not
be sound but if it weren't sound
certainly that would be an important
clue
we've talked about machine intelligence
if you think that
that is going to happen then that
looks like it's a pivot point and you
could then broadly divide
humanity's future into pre and post
super intelligence
and most of what happens
pre-superintelligence might mainly be
important insofar as it impacts how this
transition to the machine intelligence
era goes
that certainly i'm always simplifying
here but but if you accepted something
even vaguely like that it would
radically
simplify uh the task of thinking about
the future because now instead of almost
anything possibly being really important
and relevant to think about
now it's a much smaller set of
developments that
that that really could be pivotal in
this sense the concept of an existential
risk
um i think is another one of these that
that helps us
like a lens to sort of see certain
structural elements of the human
condition and its future
um you know questions about whether
there are extraterrestrials and stuff
like that they could be relevant as well
and so we've already covered a few of
these and there's a bunch of other
concepts um and ideas and arguments like
that that that together makes it now the
case almost i think
that the hard thing is to conceive of
even one
coherent future that that satisfy all of
these constraints
or one strategic picture that tells us
what we should do that that
meets all of these criteria it's so it's
not as if there's this
space where you could just make anything
up and the difficult thing is finding
some way to choose between them now it's
more that are all so many constraints
that it's hard even to figure out one
thing that kind of fits them all
um which i think is a big change
compared to say
futurism in in i don't know in the uh
70s and 80s
but i think that the implicit message
and what you're saying is that to best
prepare for the future people should
listen to the mindscape podcast because
we've talked about many of these issues
all right a good start yeah it's a very
good start all right
nick bostrom thanks so much for being on
the podcast thank you sean
[Music]
you